Sam hunt is officially married I saw  some jaws drop the 32 year old as wet  longtime girlfriend Hannah Leigh Fowler  they've been on and off since 2008 and  she reportedly inspired Sam's 2014 debut  album Sam popped the question to Hannah  just after the new year it's just that  feeling you have that heart radar that  guides us in life and reveal details  about the wedding to et at the 2017 ACM  Awards what kind of nuptials do you have  planned is it going to be intimate big  hometown destination intimate and  hometown okie low maintenance we're both  kind of introverted people for the most  part so we don't we don't like  celebrating ourselves too much if there  ever is the time to do it it's now and  it's more to celebrate the union of  marriage than it is each other and and  I'm excited about doing there